I'm kind of thinking what we want to be
able to say is then then we want these
next functions to be external download
external upload yeah ok which takes I
know it takes an external object said
I'm sorry so sometimes and this behaves
like you're all don't know that I guess
I think so so it would implicitly create
a service object if necessary and
service connect if you need to mm-hmm
but it would be would be transparent
normally because for these services
you're you store the credentials
somewhere where you don't have to prompt
if interactive input I think that's
right so external download of an s3
external object would do the right thing
am I making sense that it's a little bit
verbose with the external object
specification but I don't think that's
that problematic because I just don't
think this is a thing where people you
know I think people will survive the
verbosity um ok so then we've got
external download then we got external
upload is that wait is external download
downloading it to the external location
or downloading it to your current
location donut from your from the
external like URL download means out
download from the URL to where you are
now oh ok well or anybody who's watching
this live stream we should kind of
explain what we're doing here um this is
an internal designer view of a piece of
functionality for connecting to external
file systems and computing services and
AWS is our first example and we are
doing the design of
that should work and we might as well
just go through what we are concluding
so first of all there's a service
connect which is part of the whole
service connection family that connects
to whatever the external services that
will set up the appropriate credentials
and return a service object which at
this time we're not really making direct
you solve anywhere in here it's that
true so if you have multiple connections
there's only with us with an external
object there's only a single you're just
making use of whatever the s3 service
connection was and you assume there's
only one as three service connection in
this session right that's Christ
um I mean we could also in that extra
logic thing there we could optionally
allow a connection piece in the
Association which kanae contains the
service object you see what I'm saying
sure but as soon as it is in there then
it can die I know I know which is which
is not desirable but I mean it could die
but it could be recreated from the other
information that's in there in other
words external download if it sees I've
got a service object in there then it
says okay great I'm gonna try and use
the service object if the service object
is no longer valid
then I will reira quest the connection
but if the service object is valid then
I can just go happily along and just use
that that existing connection Surrey
requesting is a bit dangerous because as
soon as passwords and were done revolved
we don't cache them in these objects
it's not safe
no obviously not so it won't be able to
reira quest the connection but why
doesn't it pop a password dialog
I mean authentication if you do an
authentication an 11-3 if you do an
indication where you give a username
right but you haven't given a password
well actually off medication let's see
what is it called it's called password
dialog I think yes we do this actually
authentication die okay authentication -
hello
okay so we actually put database link
they use something called prompt and we
copied that which also gives us this
dialog authentication dialog but this I
don't think that's the right way to do
it I think we should use the
authentication dialog mechanism 11:3
here Brad on that now I haven't seen it
I'll try running it open close just try
running it okay fine okay that's quite
nice
okay very jolly
so just to type something in and failure
illness and parameters okay
submit anyway did it did it submit I did
but now it's stuck okay failed okay but
but normally that would return an
association of username and password yes
okay the authentication dialog works is
if you feed it in a partial result like
a username but no password then it will
not you know it will do the right thing
in terms of what it's prompts for sure
so I think that using I mean so what
that suggests is that someone err it's a
little bit too hard to see how that
exactly works because it's got a splice
in to that Association unless it's
unless there's an authentication yeah I
mean that's the right way to do it in
the external object there's an
authentication option okay okay so
there's inside this when we're
constructing this object there's an
option for there's an authentication
option and the authentication option um
might be that password thing but then
it's going to store that the point is
that you are storing globally in the
session the authentication information
correct we're not storing
Senta creation information every time
you do redo an external download you're
going back to the external key chain to
refine the authentic you're gonna
authenticate a client's but it doesn't
store the information or education
information but it's a Java object in
this case that we can't you know okay
but so so if you were handed an external
object and no authentication has been
done for that external object something
has to cause that authentication to
happen sure so yeah exactly
the first likely external download would
cause the authentication to happen
unless perhaps external object is not
purely symbolic and we'll try and
validate itself when it's weren't asked
about right there seems to make sense
that external object would be smart
enough to re-establish a connection if
it's called fine
okay so reestablishing a connection is
an external side effect type process
correct is that correct
what is an external side effects well
I'm just saying right there's no there's
no you can do it explicitly with service
connect but otherwise if you just you
know call external object yeah I said
anything right if that is if that causes
authentication to occur right there's no
visible sign of authentication yes okay
fine I see we're saying yeah and this is
kind of yucky and kind of yucky let's
think about this for a second I mean
honestly in normally like for URL
download there will be an authentication
option to URL download okay yeah extra
object should take the authentication
option and if it's built into the object
it'll try and use whatever credentials
you've given it otherwise it'll have to
prompt you I guess so and we and the
storage of the credentials should
eventually happen through our keychain
mechanism even if
our keychain is really a stub to some
external keychain for this purpose does
that make sense yeah I think so okay so
let's walk through this then so then
well we're not yet ready with keychain
so this will okay so then so service
connectors the way that you would do the
connection I mean I wonder whether this
should actually be I'm wondering whether
we should rename this family to service
object no we already have a service
object so this I see so the storage
object I mean the question is whether
service where the external download
external upload should really be service
downloaded service upload so what
happens with Dropbox with service
connects and downloading things from how
does that work how does the service
connection to Dropbox work question did
you build that we didn't but we have
updated that and okay go get on the
storage services Dropbox
query path you go input file downloading
no so there's there's what it's doing
there is specific requests in the
service connection right which by the
way we probably want to support in the
case of the AWS thing as well directly
in the service connection see what I'm
saying I see yeah
why not I mean this is lower level stuff
this is less cooked now clearly with
Dropbox we're going to need a wrapper
that takes this level of connection
let's take a look at how the path works
what is the path display so that path
display is that
the bucket name is that correct I think
the path is like the key in the bucket
you sure okay but notice the metadata
there of service over modified etc etc
as well as a Content hash yes and
presumably there is metadata like that
from s3 exactly so there's a there's a
function that gets the I don't think
that's necessarily the right thing
because that could just be properties of
the external object right well yes could
we go back to the external object
mechanism here okay so could you scroll
down to the stuff you've done for us
three here Shawn so okay so they upload
and download we think are worth having
sort of large scale functions for as
opposed to just being specific service
connection requests so so things like
bucket list one earth is SQL tables what
does that have to do with anything
that's just the model of yeah but you
know look and I think that's in database
link is not a model for anything
it's an old fully designed system if
we're if we're treating external objects
like files is there a reason we couldn't
use like copy file to do the upload in
the download either one and just you
must external object as the destination
and it can have it can have the logic
for how to support the things like the
authentication well let's talk about
that because the reason we have URL
download is because URLs have some more
tentacles that are a little different
but this doesn't these are just files
aren't they
that's Christ yes go ahead also fit
nicely with I mean you can directly copy
file into local objects or cloud objects
and stuff like that that's a very good
good good int good interface to use yeah
I agree that's not bad
okay so let's go back up to the top
there so then what we're talking about
so then we don't in fact have so we have
this external object just like we have
local object and cloud object we then
have external object but then we would
have copy file of an external object to
let's say a local object or to a file
yeah so coffee farm and so then the the
the semantics would be copy file could
be from a local object to I mean you
could go from a cloud object to an
external object and you know merrily
combine them in all possible ways yeah
exactly sort of least ability to
download or upload mini files at once
how does that work with is there a copy
directory mechanism there is isn't there
how does that work it's the copy
directory here copies - which directory
that Durer so maybe they're told
bucket well the question is maybe so but
but I think that the directory um in the
case of Dropbox obviously we want to be
able to copy directories but I think
there's also another case which is copy
multiple files to a directory which we
don't seem to have here though arguably
we should have that and also yeah just
having Moscow files like list sort of
things it could be copy files maybe well
you have like I think the Hobbit file
would be I think we can we can look
there's no reason why we can't yes we
could do that too that's a perfectly
reasonable thing to do but the most
important case would be copy a bunch of
files into a single directory so he
files into a single directory yes do we
have a directory where we do not sadly
we I mean partly because the function
directory is an active function but yeah
I mean we arguably we should rename that
current directory and it start yes um
I'm not sure that that's a doable you
know we could clearly have something
called file directory that would be the
you know directory for files but it
doesn't matter I mean any any um right
but if you have a list of external list
of files right then you can cut
certainly copy a list of files into
something which is a directory okay I
see so like if it was a list of things
then yeah even if you use the file web I
mean it would would have to check
whether that file is actually directory
absolutely yeah if the second argument
is cloud directory then it's obvious so
we would actually be support quite a
number of important cases by allowing
the first argument to be a list of files
I agree and I think that should be
implemented so I'm not sure it's
constant and the person who's who's the
keeper of copy file these days I think
Joel was working
something related to copy file in
connection with with text search okay
yeah I mean we can move this over to to
CSE that copy file singing yeah I think
that's the right place to do it okay
all right so let's keep going here so
we've now gotten rid of external upload
and download so um now in terms of the
file properties business how does that
work so let's scroll down to your
discussion of s3 again in so the file
copies you got bucket list which is
basically a directory listing yes that's
basically file names of an external
object right I exactly it'll return so
that file names thing would return a
bunch of external objects yes which our
directory is whatever in there so then a
bucket create is a create directory yes
that's easy create directory in an
external of an external object and that
external object is a pure bucket yeah so
this is a bucket objects well no no it's
a it's a if we need that we might need
to have a service s3 type bucket or
Titan fine yes yeah so it'll be service
three and then okay if you think that's
right okay all right fine so then in
terms of the metadata do we have a file
properties function we do don't we we do
let's see file
she do we have that we have we have we
can build it up from pieces like this
foul no no we have file information file
oh yeah that's file information you're
right yes yes no that is coming I think
in this version that's correct
okay that's useful so file information
is the is the thing for getting metadata
okay okay all right what else does that
so anything else is potentially so the
only issue is that if you implicitly get
the service connection right as a result
of an authentication request from trying
to do a copy file for instance okay then
yes you don't have that handle which
means that you can't then make a service
execute request to that service
connection to get other operations done
because you don't she know what the
service connection is and I'm making
sense now I mean isn't there a global
thing for for services what is the thing
for opens is it service objects what is
the thing for all opens to give you all
open service connections that's a good
question so it's objects services maybe
no Christian what's the answer to that
you know making look at the service
object there sure so that's connects
maybe we don't have such a thing maybe
we don't have a discovery mechanism for
all open services is this yes this place
all the available services but I mean we
don't have one function or object or
something to show all the correct
natural thing that's similar to our
other thing called service object
open/close which gives you all open
services so the subjects
objects plural Jets yes okay but the
problem with that it's a it's a kind of
yucky and direct way to get it I guess
although although arguably if you want
to go in actually one way to do it would
be yes I mean okay you know what the way
to do it would be given an external
object okay so this is the thing I don't
quite understand so given an external
object if it pops a an authentication
dialog requests authentication and then
comes back as an external object that is
authenticated that has a service
connection associated with it
a service object associated with it
where does it store that service object
does it store it inside the external
object I say I would say yes it stores
the live service you know and if that
thing is saved away
what is the serialization of a service
object what does it look like if you
save a service object in a file what
does it look like you just open one just
just do it just open one just create a
well service connect to Twitter isn't
gonna work it's not a public so yes it
says connects try some other random
service code could you try it yeah right
it registers fine
he says famous last words
no you authorize don't go back and go to
this list of services at the top and go
to what I try archive archive doesn't
need a fine arts header open library why
aren't you being able to click on that
there you go okay so if connectors so
it's connects okay
and to sterilize you want to do I just
want to see ting okay yes say very much
why not great now let's just do import
form of that turned a a connection ad
okay so that connection ID if you try it
in the future it'll just go blip I mean
yeah does it automatically prompt you
for it to refresh this at the the
connection ID none necessarily you can
try to quit and reevaluate that okay I
mean I'm pretty sure this won't work but
fine quit okay and then Riva know this
not connected yeah that makes sense
there's also how we implemented the s3
stuff also do the same thing okay fine
so then and what that suggests is that
you can put the service connection into
the external object right so that if you
want it out of that you just do you know
external object thing and then open
brackets quote service connection and
then it will tell you what the service
object is and you can then make a
request to that service object here what
I'm saying ah it means make sure they
understand so you saying if you make if
you want to use the external object
explain one more time okay so the
external object if you specify initially
you specify it without a service
connection okay or without a connection
I thought you did that you constructed
you construct it without a connection
this is just a dead thing that says
here's the name of the file here's the
name of the bucket etcetera turrets
okay okay so if you forget that
authentication option forget the
authentication option at the end okay so
now if you try to use that in a copy
file yes I'm gonna say I can't do that
got to it hopefully it's going to UM
let's make how this works and there's an
option for sent occation Hills I don't
understand how this works I don't
understand how this works because the
thing is just out there and it's somehow
got to have a connection specification
it's got to indirectly refer to
something which is its connection you
get what I'm saying because every
external object out there as soon as you
authenticate every external object you
could have a file with a list of a
hundred of these and they all have to
become active at the time when you make
a connection yes we just say look this
is a object now and it's not gonna work
and you can I understand that but but if
if you have to do so this question go
ahead yes you could caste the service
connection once you establish it once
and but how does it get into these
external objects or does it mean make it
mute mutable and so as soon as it has a
connection it will store it inside and
you can ask for it the way you suggest
it is always a field or with a function
yeah but I don't think we should be
mutable look was not mutable they do not
contend contain the connection state and
the only place where the connection
state shows up is when you actually do
an operation like copy file chunk and
that always takes an argument for the
first argument is a client or connection
it's not no that's not right I mean it
has to color somewhere well it could
have an authentication option oh wait I
wrote that on our yeah sure that's other
one
and that could be a service object or it
could be explicit username and password
and so on Shawn but that doesn't belong
with the operation I mean that belongs
with the object that's not clear I mean
the object is just some some symbolic
thing out there that you may or may not
be able to connect to you can still do
operations if you have a great big long
list of external objects with names you
could still do an operation even though
you can't connect to them well the
difficulty I guess also comes with the
reason that it's nice to carry the
service object with users that certain
objects aren't defined they're defined
for a particular service object and then
you have to what do you mean so example
like eel buckets you might have two
connections js3
like one account in other counts and one
bucket is for one accounts in the other
bucket is for the other count well okay
that was one thing I was asking earlier
it wasn't clear what the answer to that
was I mean it's possible so it's yeah
you can have different service objects
for different accounts it's not a common
use case but it is possible in that case
the combination of service and user
should be unique for the two different
accounts right yes so if there's an
active service connection somewhere in
your session the external object can
look for that session and two different
objects that belong to two different
accounts won't same find the same one
because it won't match both service and
user I mean we should do it the same way
as for example a browser or any other
service with handle URLs I mean you URL
contains everything needed and if
necessary it will ask for the password
and then remember that transferred for
the rest of the session I don't think
there's any more complicated problem to
solve here okay well all right let's
keep going um so
given so there are global questions that
you can ask given a particular
connection which will be gassed through
service executes yes okay so let's keep
going what other things you need for the
s3 connection that's pretty much it I'm
just gonna look at the guide page for a
cookie yeah I guess deleting something
like an object's I guess it's what I
need files for yeah bucket to me yeah I
guess the file operations give enough
for that okay so as three buckets
becomes file names right s3 buckets mm
or is that directory named that's
directory names if that was in this
analogy directory name
no no file name can give you directories
yeah
it also give you back the files in that
level yes alright let's continue okay so
I think we need to you know let's if we
try to adjust this design to use this so
we're going to use external object to
represent this thing now I think there's
additional work on external object and
we should make sure that whatever we
have is compatible with that as I said
Alan Joyce knows about that yeah so I
guess before you continue with us so
this is very nice and it will be nice to
integrate this nicely into the service
connect thing and the one question
though is for do we keep a separate AWS
Pacolet that has a separate design that
is used by no I mean if you want to I
don't care but it I don't think it
should be readily documented if that's
the internal implementation fine I think
make sense it's so close to the top
level that has no need to have any you
know extra documentation for specific to
AWS and s3 ok that's that's a lot of
this can be documented in connection
with you know external object look what
what should happen is just like in
service connections we have separate
documentation pages for each of the
services to which one can connect sure
yes yes as our object we should have
subsidiary pages for the various
different external object types yes and
in terms of people that we work on that
given that now it's a pretty top level
things I guess it would be the service
connecting to take our internal function
and make it I'm not sure about that
because it's got copy file and all those
kinds of things that integration is more
like I don't know who's worked on copy
file but I know Joel has been doing some
stuff and I mentioned before Constantine
has been doing some stuff on that model
we would be how copy file handles local
objects cloud of cloud object
fair enough and who knows I think
although I do enjoy with us yes okay
fine fine yes well let's not get young
involved in this he's um involved in
other things okay so I guess there yeah
the main thing for us like what we want
to need to do for this release at least
is like we're just gonna supply these
yeah these services we can design them
however we want you don't really catch
much right and then Roman perhaps can
help deal with actually integrating them
with copy file and so on okay
fine should be fairly straightforward
and there's a little bit of
documentation work to be done around
that okay so one question then is the
documentation so AWS link itself which
will be called by these other services
don't document it documentation but
we're not gonna have external
documentation for it because spinners
feel like it's just gonna be the same as
the you know just gonna say it copies
you know copies file copies of you know
an s3 object doesn't really matter okay
fine okay let's talk about ec2 for a
minute okay so late to the create
instance how does that relate to what
Roman will be doing in launching an
engine launching an instance of the
engine how does how does KCM launch an
instance of the engine well at the
moment it doesn't yet but the idea is
what we need is a representation an
object for remote computer resource such
as Amazon instance that is ready to
launch or has been launched
but KCM doesn't KCM have a whole bunch
of functions for X you know remote
kernel and stuff like this well we know
kernel come yeah I mean once we have I
mean at the moment we were just
providing these instances and once you
have them then you can use either remote
run or parallel or launch kernel or we
will be able to do submit tasks to them
so I think we need to think a little bit
about about a design for for this
interface for cloud computing services
because we now have quite a zoo of those
and I'm not sure whether this belongs
into the CAC meeting I mean I've
prepared a little bit of some stuff
thinking about how this fits in KCM and
and stuff like that but I mean
independent of that we need we need
these functions here for providing
representations of running Amazon
exactly
but those running instances are the same
as a running raspberry pi sitting out on
the network basically yes yes of course
I mean once it's running in terror it
has an IP address it can be reached by
SSH it can be pinged and whatever so
this this is very similar yes well so
are you proposing that there be a thing
called you know computation object or
something or remote computation resource
or some such other thing did we not have
a design for that in connection with KCM
no not yet no we never talked about it
is a design of these things there's one
case we should keep in mind and that is
these drop summation things like charity
engine that do not provide access to a
running instance but that are pure task
submission yes functionalities and there
is no reason to treat these separately
because for many many cases I mean we
can do task submission in all of these
and in some of those like the Amazon
case we can also talk to the instances
and so we should we should consider a
rather broad framework for handling all
of these one short kernels or one short
tasks submission environments well how
does how similar is that what happens
with cloud objects where they can be
well what is that and how does that good
it's the same as as cloud as cloud
submit write them out submit provides I
mean there are these
to a cloud-based so basically the cloud
base is the analog of these and Jess's
yes I mean well it's the factory that
Polites as many instances as we need and
so we have cloud evaluate for the
synchronous case we have cloud submit
and we have we could do parallel
computing with cloud kernels I mean in
fact we are doing that with the new HPC
option for the for the product route so
this all fits very nicely together I
mean I think just to be needing in a
sample meeting we need to talk about
KCM version two because I've now
realized that the focus of the current
KCM is too much at the low level of the
parallelism and we need to focus more on
the on these cloud computer based
environments because these are new they
weren't on the horizon when when I
thought about casing for the first time
and so I have a proposal for for weight
let's let's pull this off this sounds
like a good thing and that's probably
the way that this should be architected
I mean as the internal packet is in
terms of the internal Pacolet whatever
you have here is fine probably yeah
maybe this works I mean I used it last
week when before I thought we did nine
and it it works it does a it does
everything we need I mean it does
everything you need for parallelism and
a little bit of work it will also
interface nicely with submit probably
also within it and with remote one I
mean so this is all this is this is in
good shape all right we should wrap this
meeting we're kind of late here just
last thing should be documents there's
like about 20 symbols I think in the ec2
thing should we know okay no I mean
we're not let's get a proper design with
this which will not be particularly
difficult to get and then let's try to
get perhaps Roman can help hook these
things up to it I mean that design may
be largely a shell that just calls
through to these lower level padlet
functions but for this particular case
okay so very quick question to endless
as well so one idea we had at the
beginning
was that we can expose this on github
for users and they can easily hook up
any other functions that they need from
AWS probably black line I don't have a
problem with that I don't see a problem
with that I mean I don't think that um
yeah I mean I think so the documentation
was I guess there yeah the documentation
will be nice then if you want to put it
in you can put it in I I'm just saying
that I think in terms of what we
officially support it should be the
higher-level form that is you know other
things
okay this is like a driver basically
Sean but is it an issue if there's for
documentation is in the in the bulbs no
as as a separate AWS I don't think it's
a huge problem but I don't think it's
necessarily gonna get built onto the web
and things okay Sean unless that happens
automatically I mean I I don't think did
somebody know whether that happens
automatically I think it does like
database link is definitely built like
that on the web
well then we need to have a further
discussion about it okay I mean if we're
lucky we can actually try and get this
hook up to copy file on so undone
quickly I think we should look at
whether that's possible it may be a very
straightforward cosmetic thing in which
case we can avoid all of this discussion
well the ec2 stuff is still there's a
lot of options and things you didn't
have that that okay fine that's going to
require a separate discussion let's have
that discussion in connection with
Romans if if Sebastian if you can be
part of the place where Roman is
presenting and maybe we should fork of a
separate meeting for that um oh boy
that's complete yeah it's complicated
this is already missing a lot of options
experimental thing I guess what what the
heck I mean we can have it as an
experimental thing it's gonna go away
and be subsumed into something else but
that's what experimental means okay fine
I just we don't have a lot of bandwidth
to go and you know if you think I know
okay
fine alright those who are watching on
the exciting livestream I hope you had
an interesting time here and actually we
have another designer view that is also
going to be live stream that will start
in a few minutes on completely different
topic
you